it's PS plus time again the mid-month
update that adds a bunch of games to the
extra and premium tiers of the
PlayStation plus gaming catalog this
time there is only 13 games to go
through so let's do this Devil May Cry 5
special edition is the headliner of the
month Dante returns in one final
adventure to slay even more demons with
super slick Gung Fu and other balletic
forms of weapon Mastery they're so fast
this video probably isn't rendering very
well right now the hack and slash-a-thon
has three playable characters this time
with Dante his brother Nero and this new
guy V using all their style and Charisma
we push through a story which changes
the brothers forever especially Nero can
the lads defeat the demon king from
Conquering the human world only one way
to find out jump in and to clarify the
PS4 version is the standard edition
while the PS5 has the special edition
variant Devil May Cry 5 has a Metacritic
score of 89 out of 100 so you really
should play this one back for blood is
hitting both the PS4 and PS5 on January
17th the spiritual successor to left for
dead as an unlikely team of survivors
band together to take on the undead the
reason I bring up Left 4 Dead is because
it's made by those people they don't
have the rights to that name so they
made back for blood instead and it takes
everything they've learned about
first-person shooters and the zombie
apocalypse and adds a new mechanic to it
cards by building a deck of cards we can
buff the way we fight specializing in
certain ways maybe you want to tank more
hits there's a card that gives you more
Health maybe your reload is taking too
long just find the card to tweak it
maybe you need more bullets or you need
to move faster you get the idea cards
adapt the game which should promote
replayability in a squad online with
friends this game excels back for blood
on Metacritic is a very impressive 77
out of 100.
let's take things down a notch take a
look at the amazing life is strange on
the piano S4 a narrative story with
branching paths one of the coolest
mechanics in the game is Max's ability
to control time rewinding it preventing
a friend from being Shot opens up a new
series of events as you become an
investigator as well as experiencing a
coming-of-age kind of story that has
consequences with puzzle solving
short-term and long-term impacts to your
decisions and six endings to uncover
life is strange is a Showcase of the
level's narrative stories achieved in
their Heyday and Metacritic says it's an
85 out of 100 very impressive oh and
there's more should you need more Max
and Chloe in your life after finishing
that game the prequel life is strange
before the storm is here as well
fleshing out Chloe's life before that
gunshot Was Heard Metacritic says 77
next Dragon Ball Fighters a tag team
fighter in which we choose our favorite
characters from Dragon Ball and beat the
living heck out of each other the
fighting is not as deep as something
like Tekken or Street Fighter instead a
simplified four button method is here no
intricate combos Ultra simple and it
needs to be as you're managing three
Fighters hopping in and out of battle
the depth comes from understanding each
character's unique abilities like Nappa
he can plant and grow Cybermen to fight
alongside him there's also a voice
acting story to play through if you're a
fan of the show Metacritic says Dragon
Ball Fighters is an 87 out of 100. this
month's open world game is Just Cause 4
reloaded I adore these games but
technically they do have issues we play
as Rico Rodriguez who is sent to an
island controlled by a mysterious
military group it's then our job to take
down the dictator pulling the strings by
causing as much damage and destruction
as possible all while knowing your
grappling hook and wingsuit will keep
you safe from harm well most of the time
just cause has a great weather system
that can tear up the world from Beneath
Your Feet pulling vehicles and buildings
into tornadoes and snowstorms the
reloaded version of the game comes
complete with a weaponized wingsuit I
never knew that existed a stealth micro
Jet and more things which came after the
game was released Metacritic says avoid
this as It's a 65 out of 100 whereas I
say play it good luck finding someone to
trust something unlike everything else
on the list today is Erica a full motion
video game like life is strange Erica is
an interactive story which builds into a
thriller Erica struggles with nightmares
and more often than not they seep into
her Consciousness after receiving a
severed hand in the mail things get real
so will you try it please let me know
Metacritic says 69 where percent omno is
next a Serene single-player puzzle game
we are tasked to find out what happened
to A Lost Civilization as we find new
biomes the skills we learn can be
implemented Elsewhere for example you'll
learn to ski in the snowy mountain tops
and then that ability can let you ski on
Sand Dunes later in the game each
mechanic added becomes part of the next
puzzle constantly building up your
knowledge base running at about 4 hours
of time oh no does not want to take over
your life for the rhythm game
enthusiasts out there please look at
sayonara Wild Heart a young lady falls
through the roof of her home and lands
on a skateboard and that's it that's the
premise the music begins and we skate to
the track the gameplay consists of
moving your character through the icons
shown on screen and watch as everything
evolves including the thing you're
riding on which becomes more interesting
like a motorbike or a moose reviewers
say the story does build and ultimately
this is an 82 out of 100 so don't get
put off by those visuals this is a good
game jet the fast shot is next on our
list an exploration game that invites
the player to take an Interstellar trip
to find a future for the rest of us here
on Earth May is a scout who surveys the
new world we encounter as each planet is
visited the story becomes more clear and
we find out exactly why we must keep
exploring get the fireshore review say
this should be avoided 65 out of 100 and
to end there are three more classic
games added to the premium tier list all
from the PS1 era siphon filter 3
completes that trilogy as Gabe and Zing
have been blamed for a fatal virus
ravaging the Earth Star Wars demolition
lets us choose from 10 iconic Star Wars
vehicles and then do battle with them
and finally HotShots golf too okay and
that's our month a much quicker video
this month as there is only half as many
games as usual I'm Adam you're awesome
let me know your opinions I'll see you
soon